quel âge avez vous les atomes qui sont
en vous ont plus de 13 milliards
d'années
l'adn qui est dans vos cellules descend
en droite ligne d'un organisme
apparu il ya près de 4 milliards
d'années
mais cette merveille qu'est votre corps
ces milliards de composants qui vous
permettent de me comprendre tout cela
si tout se passe demain comme
aujourd'hui disparaître a très
probablement avant la fin de ce siècle
certains si comme moi vous avez 55 ans
donc si vous avez 55 ans en un certain
sens vous avez beaucoup de chance durant
près de deux cent mille ans avant les
villes avant les civilisations
quasiment personne n'atteignait l'âge de
50 ans mais en en outre sens vous n'avez
pas de chance
vous n'avez pas de chance parce que
vivre deux fois plus longtemps
qu'auparavant
c'est insuffisant c'est largement
insuffisant pour s'aimer pour
s'entraider pour découvrir le monde et
certains pensent que d'ici 40 ans d'ici
30 ans d'ici même peut-être vingt ans
nous pourrions mettre fin aux maladies
liées au vieillissement
est ce que c'est de l'égoïsme
certainement pas c'est une forme de
solidarité envers les personnes les plus
âgées
d'abord est-ce que c'est de la naïveté
est ce que c'est un rêve
oui oui c'est un rêve mais nous vivons
des temps de rêve qui deviennent réalité
comment pouvons nous arriver à lutter
contre les maladies liées au
vieillissement
il ya d'abord les les produits la
metformine la rapamycine la très
classique aspirine lorsqu on les donne à
des souris qui avancent en âge en
laboratoire ou à des personnes qui
avancent en âge elles permettent de
gagner
des années de vie pour les êtres humains
et des chercheurs des milliers de
chercheurs de par le monde tente de
découvrir d'autres substances d'autres
composants pour les plus loin il y a
ensuite les thérapies géniques
vous connaissez très probablement la
technologie de type crise perd 4,9
tout ce qui permet de changer le
patrimoine génétique des générations à
venir et même de nos cellules le
patrimoine d'un patrimoine génétique à
nous et pour illustrer combien c'est une
source d'espoir je voudrais vous
présenter deux caméléon de la grande île
de madagascar
kalumba par sony et four siffert
labourdine kaloum aptar sony vis à vis
de caméléon durant période qui peut
durer 5 à 10 ans à gauche faut s'y faire
l'aborder lui c'est le vertébrés
terrestres à la vie la plus longue la
plus courte du monde
il naît grandit se reproduit et puis
meurt de vieillesse
même dans des circonstances idéales en
nettement moins de six mois
cela veut dire que avec des patrimoines
ces deux organismes pour des patrimoines
génétiques proches en changeant pas
tellement on ne changera pas tellement
dans le patrimoine génétique nous
pourrions gagner beaucoup d'années de
vie il y a des baleines qui peut vivre
deux sigles il ya des espèces de requins
qui vivent 4 500 ans probablement
et puis plus loin de nous des arbres qui
peut vivre pendant des millénaires
est ce que il est envisageable vraiment
de vaincre le vieillissement très
probablement le vieillissement est
cependant quelque chose d'extrêmement
complexe vous avez le schéma de ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui en 2016 et on ne sait
pas tout donc c'est complexe mais
l'humanité est faite de franchissement
de frontière
ce qu'on l'on croyait jusqu'ici
impossible devient possible
je voudrais vous donner un exemple dit
un peu plus d'un siècle le vol plus
lourd que l'air
1896 lord kelvin le grand alors qu'elle
vit une aventure de degrés kelvin
déclaré
qu' il n'avait pas la moins le moindre
espoir à la moindre molécule disait-il
d'espoir par rapport à l'aviation en
dehors des montgolfières l'humanité fait
de dépassement par exemple aussi entre
1957 premiers objets dans l'espace
premier soyouz et 1969 premiers êtres
humains sur la lune
douze ans seulement c'est tellement
extraordinaire quand qu'aujourd'hui les
gens pensent que ce n'est pas vrai il
faudrait un changement de paradigme se
rendre compte que nous ne devons plus
nous attaquer aux maladies
l'une par une mais à l'ensemble du
processus de vieillissement pour cela
des investissements privés des
investissements surtout public pour par
la solidarité pour les personnes âgées
sont nécessaires et aussi nous pourrons
nous servir de l'intelligence
artificielle êtres humains aujourd'hui
c'est savoir que l'intelligence disons
mécanique pourra un jour peut-être nous
dépasser dans presque tous les domaines
cela comprend des aspects très risqué
dangereux je ne vais pas m'étendre ici
mais c'est aussi une source d'espoir
tout à fait considérable et s'il nous en
servons pour les recherches grand
matière de vie plus longue en bonne
santé
cela remonte considérablement les
chances que cela nous soit utile pour
permettre des simuler des expériences
sur des cellules sur des animaux de
laboratoire sur des mêmes sur des êtres
humains et surtout pour mieux comprendre
le cerveau de l'humain et les maladies
neurodégénératives qui sont une cause
majeure de décès de due au
vieillissement mais certains d'entre
vous se diront mais finalement pourquoi
vivre beaucoup plus longtemps
à quoi ça sert alors d'abord aujourd'hui
nous ne mourons quasiment plus lorsque
nous avons une maladie que de maladies
liées au vieillissement
c'est sept décès sur 10 cent dix mille
personnes vont décéder aujourd'hui dans
le monde
c'est 90% des décès dans un pays comme
la france et donc 6
vous considérez comme moi qu'il n'y a
rien de plus important que le droit à la
vie humaine et que c'est la condition de
tous les autres droits mais il n'y a
rien de plus important aujourd'hui que
de permettre de sauver des vies par ce
biais là puisque c'est statistiquement
le plus important alors bon moi je
voudrais vivre trois siècles au moins
pour pouvoir faire un exposé comme celui
ci dans plusieurs langues
et puis voir même sans accent belge bon
mais il ya également des raisons de
solidarité des raisons sociales des
raisons collective
d'abord l'environnement si les femmes et
les hommes savent qu'ils vont pouvoir
vivre pendant des siècles qui ne vont
plus mourir de vieillissement
s'ils savent cela ils seront beaucoup
plus en plus beaucoup plus prudent par
rapport à leur planète
parce que pour pouvoir avoir un corps
durable pendant une longue durée il vous
faut une planète durable également mais
il y a aussi encore plus important la
question de la violence et la question
de la violence liés à ce qu'on appelle
parfois la démocratisation de la
violence le fait que suite aux progrès
technologiques
il devient de plus en plus facile
malheureusement de se tuer les uns les
autres par rapport à ça un aspect c'est
de rendre l'être humain plus résilient
plus solide plus résistant et donc dans
un monde futur nous pouvons imaginer que
nous arriverons à ce que la vie humaine
parce qu'elle devient presque sans
limitation de durée
nous pouvons imaginer que la vie humaine
que tu que tu es quelqu'un
ce ne sera plus seulement accéléré son
décès mais ce soit vraiment un acteur
totalement inimaginable ce serait plus
seulement inacceptable ce serait
inimaginable
impensable de mettre fin à une vie alors
j'ai parlé des thérapies géniques que
j'ai parlé également des des produits je
n'ai pas encore parlé des
nanotechnologies parmi les pistes
possibles pour une vie beaucoup plus
longue en bonne santé il ya aussi les
scénes olitique il ya aussi la paradis
aux les microchirurgie les imprimantes
médical 3 3d toutes ces recherches
peuvent être combinées ça c'est
important à dire également toutes ces
recherches et toutes ces recherches
certains des rhumes ça va nous rendre
moins humain ça va nous changer
oui ça va nous changer de l'intérieur
mais ça va nous changer de l'intérieur
pour nous rendre en fait plus humain de
l'extérieur nous rendre plus humain plus
longtemps et donc j'en arrive à quand
allons nous commencer quand allons nous
commencer à lutter contre l'ensemble des
maladies liées au vieillissement et bien
par rapport à cela en fait la raison
pour laquelle vous probablement vous
vous dites oui finalement ça n'est pas
tellement une bonne idée c'est parce que
le la mort par vieillissement
aujourd'hui c'est un fait d'abord la mer
pablisme ans aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose qu'en réalité vous ne souhaiteriez
pas à votre pire ennemi si vous pouviez
le lui éviter même pas votre belle-mère
mais n'avait pas le choix
vous allez mourir sans progrès
technologiques
vous n'avez pas le choix et donc que
fait l'esprit humain cette merveille
qu'est notre cerveau par rapport à
quelque chose qui est à la fois
insoutenable est inévitable il le
transforme de manière inconsciente en
quelque chose de positif en quelque
chose de boer en quelque chose de une
belle-mère renouvellement des
générations en fait tout ça est faux la
belle mort de vieillesse est dans les
films quasiment uniquement dans les
films et peut-être que la mort pamiers
se pourrait rejoindre la peste le
choléra la mort des enfants parmi
les inventions de la nature dont nous ne
voulons plus il a des airs de
l'invention de la nature mais il ya des
inventions de la nature dont beaucoup
vont petit à petit nous débarrasser et
nous sommes de plus en plus nombreux à
faire un rêve à faire un rêve que un
jour dans un futur pas tellement éloigné
dans un monde pas tellement différent du
nôtre
les femmes et les hommes se retourneront
vers aujourd'hui ils se retourneront et
ils diront en ce début du 21ème siècle
cela ne fut pas facile de lutter pour
une vie en bonne santé est beaucoup plus
longue cela ne fut pas facile
médicalement scientifiquement
techniquement mais cela ne fut pas
facile non plus socialement parce qu'il
y avait toutes ces pubs 7
cet aspect inconscient d'acceptation ce
ne fut pas facile mais il le réaliser il
était une fois un monde dans lequel il
n'était plus seulement obligatoire de
chercher à mourir dans la dignité mais
il devint possible de vivre beaucoup
plus longtemps dans la dignité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]